قال الى الماسك مالك منصه تويتر ان شركه
التواصل الاجتماعي قررت تاجيل اطلاق خدمه
الاشتراك بالعلامات الزرقاء وهو تاخير عن
الجدول الزمني المبدئي لاعاده الخدمه على
المنصه وارجع ماسك في تغريده على تويتر
سبب تاجيل اعاده اطلاق علامه التحقق
الزرقاء الى ضروره التحقق والحصول على ثقه
عاليه في حال انتحال الهويات مضيفا انه قد
يعرض استخدام لون مختلف لمؤسسات عن
الافراد تم الطرح اختيار الاشتراك المفتوح
لاي شخص على استعداد للدفع في وقت سابقا
من هذا الشهر لمساعده تويتر على زياده
الارادات بينما عاده واوقف الخدمه بعد ما
انتشرت الحسابات المزيفه وقال حينما ان
الخدمه ستتم اعاده اطلاقها في التاسع
والعشرين من نوفمبر وفي ملف تويتر ايضا
اطلقت شركات منافسه شرعا ان كنت لا تحب
ماسك تعالى وعمل معنا الاستقطاب الموظفين
السابقين تويتر من ذوي الكفاءات
والاستفاده من خبراتهم وتجاربهم